لقد مارست الرياضة، نعم، قليلًا، كما قال الإرهابيون عنك
لقد قمت باللياقة البدنية، قالوا لي أنها مهمة جدًا
أفعل ذلك لقد انضموا كما لو أنهم أيضًا
لقد مارسوا اللياقة البدنية، لا، لكن نعم، كان هناك تدريبات منخفضة، نعم
أنا وأنت فعلنا ذلك ثم ضربتها ولأن
قالوا إنها على الرغم من أنها كانت تمارس اللياقة البدنية، إلا أنها فازت
هي دعونا نتعامل معها ثم واحدة منهم
نطقها الشاب ولوّح بيديه، لكنه أحضرها
منشفة حتى لا يسمح له بلمسي سأكون امرأة
مرحباً كثيراً، المرأة مقدسة، هناك امرأة
كانت مالكا تتحدث معي عن كيفية الحفاظ على لحم الخنزير
لقد أوضحنا لهم أنه حتى معنا في بعض الأحيان يكون لدينا كيان كامل
الوقت الذي وضعوا فيه الراديو ولكن سألناهم إذا كان ذلك ممكنًا
اجلب لنا
سُئلنا في التحالف عما يمكن أن يكون فقالوا
نعم تدرب على أوفير يوسي وزميله الواضح الذي فتح
ويشعرون بالحرب أنها عتاب وكانت ممتلئة
شعرت طفرات الانفجار القريبة وكأنها ستضرب المبنى
تماما كما كان مخيفا
عندما كانت هناك قنابل أدركت أنها ظل كما لو كنت تفهم
هناك حرب هناك فرق بين القنابل وظلها
بسبب الظل يرتعش كل شيء، وما لهم حتى يسمعوا صوتًا
لا شيء كما لو أن هذا هو السبب في أن كل يوم يمر يجب أن يكون
اعادتهم كما اسم الهلال ايضا تفجيرات
تيحال لم يكن خفيفا
يوم لم يكن هناك شعور بالوقت سمعت كل شيء
الانفجارات
إسرائيل
مشهور جدا
كبير
وكانت هناك عدة مرات قلت لنفسي في النهاية أنا
سيموت من صواريخ إسرائيل وليس من حماس، ثم ذات يوم
نحن واحد
في قذائف
والمنزل يشبه البيت المزدوج، المنزل المجاور
قصفنا ونصف جدار من النوافذ، كل شيء تحطم علينا
ونفهم أننا بحاجة إلى الترحيل
من هناك
نحن نتعرض للضغط والاهتزاز والاهتزاز وكل شيء زجاجي
وذهبت إلى النظارات في الرأس الذي أخذونا من خلاله
سيارة الإسعاف مع ديفيد متنكرًا
والجثة هي رؤية التخريب العقلي وهو ليس كذلك
اليمن تقول أن الأمر بسيط جدًا وهو كذلك حقًا
إنها مناقشة كما لو كنا نعيش في استوديوهات
Mlarlers بشأن مسألة المعاملة التالية أو
كم يُعطى وما يُعطى هي مسألة حياة
ومقارنة بموت قيمنا الأخلاقية، فإن الدولة لن تكون قادرة على ذلك
إن الوجود على هذا النحو هو أمر بسيط ولكنه في الواقع ليس كذلك
التبسيط بسيط وأعظم صعوبة
هو الذي كان لي في تلك اللحظة
ومن الواضح أن واجب بلادنا هو إعادة
معي، ولكن منذ ذلك الحين وأنا أقاتل من أجل ذلك لأنه مفاجئ
ليس واضحًا تمامًا، أقول إن روحي قد جرفت
شعرت براحة هنا في اللوحة أن الأصوات كانت كذلك
يبدو الأمر كذلك، لكن يجب أن أقول إنه ليس كذلك
أشعر دائمًا أنها الأولوية القصوى
[موسيقى]